gilles vous avez quelque chose avait je
crois que ce qu'on attend tous la petite
pépite
et oui jean michel maire qui débutait ce
we comédie caumartin au théâtre pour ses
trois premiers jours mais j'avais
annoncé un os fragiles a bien eu lieu
alors là des extraits du spectacle jean
louis mairet marocain alors déjà le
michel on voit que vous ne perdez pas
vos vieux réflexes à moment il est
question de saisie on regarde c'est tout
c'est des messages de votre canapé
oui c'est comme si moi je vous parlais
votre chemin c'est bon à la pièce
jean-michel pas croire qu'il a perdu son
ami mais en réalité c'est pas vraiment
le cas regardez comme ils jouent bien
mais ce n'est pas bien de philippe tout
ceci comme ils l'ont fait contre eux est
en train de crever lien juste avaler à
tuband des laxatifs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a fait du contexte n'avons pas
grand-chose de sa dame nommée à la ferme
ont été demandées au public leur avis
sur la pièce de jean michel maire et
après je vois un autre extrait regarde
mais ça me dépite obama il est
formidable et j'ai passé une très belle
soirée superbe
il a un peu mal à discuter a parlé mais
sinon j'ai été plutôt bon
[Musique]
c'est tout moi c'était super on a bien
rigolé sont pensés dans le contient
non sortez moi je pense qu'il va
continuer je les avais bien entier moi
parce qu'il a il a une gueule entre
guillemets jean-michel vient toujours
[Applaudissements]
nous saluons la dernière reste raymond
janvier et après c'est une question
posée parce qu'on va donner une info sur
ce qui s'est passé vendredi soir vous me
dire si c'est vrai ou pas regarder il a
les larmes aux yeux non non non non mais
c'est vrai j'ai fait moi je connais pas
c'est une aventure qui regardait alors
on a un extrait de vous qui vous
négociez avec un inspecteur de police en
utilisant un mégaphone revient alors à
michel
jean michel est un garçon qui est venu
voir qui s'appelle stéphane larue qui
m'a dit que vous ne bafouille et
parvenez pas bafouiller mais vous avez
oublié des répliques avec les autres
comédiens mais c'est vrai c'est pas fou
ouais bah oui j'ai c'était ma plus
grande peur c'est d'avoir un trou de
mémoire
j'en ai eu un ou deux la deuxième fois
c'est l'autre acteur qu'à rattraper le
coup et la première fois c'est vrai que
je suis rattraper aux branches mais
malheureusement de deux pages plus loin
un trou dans la pièce xala produits
[Applaudissements]